I thank you yes sir Alexandra is in the
studio with us welcome Alexandra
congratulations well your tournament is
very hard to watch for me especially
it's a it's a real roller coaster
unfortunately
well your game we will not analyze all
the games here but let's have a look at
this position uh your move Bishop B4 is
quite a rare move but I think by
transposition you can get to those
positions so probably I didn't know that
this line
uh would happen because there are so
many lines in the um this open rui Lopez
and she didn't have any games
so it just shows that there was a game
actually in Saint Louis between shankunt
and Sivan I think was this bishop of
four king cage one and okay I thought
that it's relatively fresh idea of
course it should be about equal but
unfortunately I mean that's
nowadays Syria so
you're opponent surprised you but you
surprised her oh she didn't surprise
because I was expected I was expecting
the open rui Lopez but I didn't know
which line because there are several
pretty drawish lines and you're kind of
trying to
come up with an idea and every single
one of them so this one was not
okay that was just one of the
possibilities and yeah so Quincy it
didn't look at how much it would be
small inaccuracy what did you expect in
this position well I don't know I didn't
know what to expect and use it in this
game between Shankar and Sivan King I
think what played there was another game
with Queen B6 which is also quite
inaccurate because of Bishop G5 and then
F4 and G4
but couldn't see it I mean at least it
guard it's guarding the square G4 and
even though G4 is still possible after
Bishop E7 but I thought
your eyes are
I'm not in this kind of
um like
right now my conditions are not the best
one to go for such complications
so I decided to play four by the way we
switched the computer off because we
decided to analyze this game because it
was very highly complicated from a human
perspective I wanted to know what
Alexandra sings here so after Queen City
you took Bishop Bishop B7 and you went
for the typical idea yes because she was
fine it's clear that she's going to play
G4 and I decided to like prepare the
Contra play on the a file after that and
here it's at every moment there is some
kind of choice which is which makes
difficult for black to play Rook A7 for
example Rook D7 was possible and I was
like hesitating whether to take just on
D7 and take on T4 and okay it still
should be a draw but I'm kind of easier
to play for me
ah there was another possibility but
okay but it takes C3 yeah I was thinking
for a very long time I was choosing
between Community B1 and queen F3 but I
didn't see anything because the idea is
that after Rook G7 there's Bishop F5 or
at least
uh but of course Rook G7 is a mistake
and I didn't see anything after Queen to
E6 Queen F3 Queen E6 and uh well then
depending on what I do see four Bishop
C5 that's why I played Queen B1 and she
surprised me with Bishop H4 I didn't
expect Bishop H4 after Queen B1 yes
Bishop H4 I didn't calculate at all
because I was thinking only about Queen
E6 instead
and the idea is that if I take on a 5
she takes was the queen yes and I take
she takes I take I mean and then there
is Rook F4 and rookie a doesn't help
that's why after
um Rook D2 in this line
it's a draw so after Queen is six B
takes a sphere Rook G2 I was considering
H3 H3 preparing all these ideas was
Queen B5 rookie seven and Bishop F5 well
still should be a draw but Bishop H4
somehow it surprised me and then she
played before I don't know whether she
went for the spawn sacrifice or she
simply blundered because after she takes
before she takes before okay Queen takes
before is possible but I think even
stronger is Bishop B3 well at least I
was going to play Bishop B3 King kj8
Rook C1
and then queen bee through C2 C7 I
didn't see anything for black hair I
mean well it looks very convincing yeah
well back rank is very weak and it's
always scary but uh Rook G7 is coming so
she played C4 and I thought okay I have
an extra pawn my position should be good
and I spent a lot of time here and I I
went yeah B5 although I'm not sure
because there were other moves like
Quincy one Queen A1 I mean many moves
that I was considering just to protect
the square on D2 even instead of B5 I
liked at some point Rook D1 a lot but
then I Bishop of two she plays and
somehow I didn't know what to do yeah I
need to go away but after Rook G2
it's hard to resist a B5 I mean you feel
that it should be winning of course she
has country play Rook D1 C3 and I
thought that I should be winning and I
have a lot of time and I thought okay I
will try to figure it out but then after
Queen C5 of course I missed it
completely
then this idea Queen F2 Queen E1
and well I decided to play it safe but
apparently I missed something right okay
but Queen A2 was another option that I
was considering and I liked a lot King
h8 through K8 I have okay eight yes so
the same idea like trying to but then
Bishop GH please
and I was calculating here like
something like even B7
um Queen F2 Rook G1
I mean just not to blunder anything you
know and I mean I liked it too
um I don't know what is evaluation I uh
and but no it's but okay but I decided
that Queen just Rook D7 is is safer but
apparently yes here yes here we at least
I can tell you because in this position
we saw that after Rook D7 uh black had
this incredible uh possibility to save
the game or at least to stay in the game
after object too because you cannot take
it very unfortunately I mean that would
be very unpleasant to see on the board
of course yes so but I shouldn't Miss
such possibilities for what was in time
pressure here well she liked her plan
with Queen E1 but I don't think it's so
dangerous because okay I I captured City
here I was somehow choosing I couldn't
couldn't choose what is stronger Queen
B3 King hh3
and play in this position
um well because she needs to retreat her
Bishop to E7 for example and then I play
B7 Rook B8 something like this yes yes
we need two queen G4 yes that was I was
missing and that's when I saw it I
thought okay no it's not it's not the
way to go yeah exactly because I was at
first considering it and that's why I
played Rook F1
I mean but in this position you're
always afraid to blunder or something
Queenie too because he always wonder
whether you have to include this check
or not on a21 B3 whether you need to
play B7 and you try to
um like evaluate all those
complications but okay I went and you
don't want to anymore I don't I mean
after yesterday's game when I just
completely you know
gave away a huge Advantage you always
feel like you you can do the same in the
next game so Rook B8 yes here but I
didn't see what she can do no no this is
completely winning okay it's scary Four
Queens on the board you're always afraid
of you know blundering something but
okay yeah it's quite safe
Queen G1
and well it was quite a thriller
Alexander thank you very much for for
all of us
Baltimore is the last round of the
tournament that's a good news and well
what are your feelings so far
well unfortunately I've given away too
many points I mean this tournaments I
knew that okay two tournaments in a row
is quite physically demanding already
but I got I mean sick and I needed you
know to to play with this cold and it's
of course didn't help
and but again I think I'm playing here
uh better than I played in Cyprus and
the quality of the game of the games
sometimes very good of course this whole
situation was taking away my hope like
the whole point it didn't help I mean it
took away some energy not even physical
energy but emotional energy and it it
matters but again as long as I win at
least I mean even after losing but it's
already good but because in Nicosia for
example out of 11 rounds I won only one
and here it's been already quite a few
thank you Alexander
thank you and indeed our congratulations
we thought it was a thriller